Lee Alpert, thank you for being on my show
20 Minute Leader.
It's so good to have you.
Hi, Michael, how are you?
I'm doing great.
So, every guest that I have on
I ask ahead of time
how do I pronounce their name
because I flunk about 50% of the names
with my Israeli accent usually.
But now, since we know each other
for I think about like 12 years,
I didn't have to do that.
So, I feel like this is smooth sailing.
12 years.
Lee, you were at Stanford together.
You helped teach courses
within Stanford Computer Science,
helping other students that are
a few quarters or years behind you
with your new expertise;
product management intern at Intuit;
incredible experiences both in Hong Kong
but also in Greece, working with IsraAID;
and now, most recently, a new program
that we'll hear about near the end.
Lee, I'd love to talk about your journey,
and I'd love to talk about your role
as a section leader at Stanford
and all the other things that I mentioned.
But first of all, who are you Lee Alpert?
Yeah. Hi, everybody listening.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
I'm Lee.
I grew up mostly
between New York and Israel,
so I personally think
I got the best of both worlds
in that deal.
It's food wise, culture wise,
and just seeing being able to contrast
those two cultures,
that's been incredible.
Give me two sentences on that,
the growing up on the line
between New York and Tel Aviv,
what was that like?
I think it was really interesting,
especially because of the politics
surrounding the Middle East and Israel
and getting perspective on that
from both within
and managing to take a step back
and see the global view on that.
I think it gave me
a very well-rounded perspective.
And sometimes it's hard
because you feel like you're always
maybe disagreeing
or you're always defending
or you're always
in these tough conversations.
Well, I have to say that, for me,
it was always a dissonance that especially
when I was in the IDF, taking part
and understanding both sides of the story
and then all of a sudden
traveling for the summer to New York
and opening The New York Times
and seeing things that I didn't really see
in the Israeli news, right?
That's something
that's really interesting.
Yes, definitely.
And I think it goes both ways.
Sometimes you're seeing things
in the states that you never see
or just in the international papers
that you never see in Israel.
And sometimes,
now there are a lot of protests
going on in Israel.
And I think the voice
that hasn't been heard in a while
in Israel is becoming very vocal.
And to me, that's very exciting.
And that maybe isn't
in the front headlines internationally.
And it makes sense why that isn't so.
But it does help place you
in a more global sense.
100%.
Yeah. I think growing up with that
was very important
in shaping my perspectives on that.
And it's definitely something
I'm still always learning how to navigate,
both with those two cultures
and any others I'm experiencing.
Well, just as a dramatic shift to this
to go between between Israel and New York
throughout the years,
you went to the Israel Defense Forces,
you spent several years there
being with it, primarily Israelis,
and then one clear day you wake up
and you were at Stanford University
in a completely different world.
Start with that first experience.
Tell me a little bit about the IDF
and what was that experience like for you?
So, I was a medic,
which I have absolutely loved.
It was really incredible.
And I think what I always say
of my time in the Army is,
it was so incredibly different
from anything I had done before
or will do after.
It was just so unique.
We had attended
an international school beforehand.
So, a lot of people
we went to school with,
and there was a variation,
a lot went to foreign affairs,
I ended up as a medic in a very small base
in the Golan Heights
by the Syrian community.
Why medic? i thought that you would go
into a variety of places,
I didn't think medic would be one of them.
Not because it's not fantastic,
because I just didn't realize
that you had an interest in a medic.
Yeah. I guess,
it was something I fell into.
I definitely wanted to try something new.
I wanted that intense experience
of being on a smaller base,
being on a base where I would spend
bigger chunks of time there.
And I really got that.
I was exposed to all types of people
I never would have met
from every socioeconomic status,
that's really important.
And then being a medic
and especially in the military,
I think, if you study medicine
and of course I understand why,
but if you study medicine
in really any other space,
takes a long time
before you're poking someone.
Whereas in the IDF,
because of resources and just time,
it's really you're just going
and you're learning by practicing
on each other.
And it can get a little gory.
Medics getting fun
for starting to like that gore.
But I loved it.
I realized, I really liked
the component of helping people.
I liked the more intense training.
And you never know
until you're really in the situation.
But it was cool to learn about myself
that I could handle that
and that I was calm under pressure.
I think that was, I even sometimes
was made fun of for it a bit.
Soldiers would come in panicking,
and the first thing I would do
I don't ask what's wrong, I just,
"Okay, relax. Everyone take a breath."
And I think that applies
to anything in life.
And same as really just learning to work
with limited resources
and making things happen.
I have to say, so, a lot of people,
especially in around Silicon Valley,
they talk about the startup nation.
And one of the things that Singer
and his co-author talked about
in the Start-up Nation book
is this idea of resilience
and the quick path to maturity
through the IDF.
And while a lot of them are talking about
the 8200 or the elite intelligence units
as key factors for the startup nation,
people like also Eric Schmidt,
they talk about this exact
what you're talking about
this idea that you're being faced,
you're being placed
in these high stress situations.
And at the age of 18, 19, you learn
that the most important thing you can do
when somebody comes in panicking
is to calm them down
and calmly assess the situation.
And so, for me, that's a perfect example
of also something that I felt
that I gained through the IDF.
But I'd love to also transition out
to Stanford and hear about
what are that experiences like,
moving from putting the uniform down,
getting on a plane and finding yourself
in the beautiful Silicon Valley
in one of the most beautiful campuses
in the world.
Yeah, definitely.
It happened really fast.
I was sending in my applications
while hot spotting from my bunk bed
in the Golan Heights.
And then, within the span
of less than a year,
I was going from being a medic to,
I probably waitressed or bartended a bit,
got a little bit of time to travel,
and then I was a student
at Stanford University
which still blows my mind sometimes.
And I think I knew it would be a change.
And I knew it would be hard
to go back into school
after being out for a while.
And in some ways, it was even more so
than what I expected.
There was definitely one night
where I re-taught myself
what basic trigonometry was
the night before.
I'm still trying to re-teach myself.
So, you're fine.
Oh, yeah. When you hear everyone talking
about how they forgot
about their math over summer
and then they're just nodding, yeah.
Yeah, those three, four years ago, right.
But it's been an incredible journey.
I got so lucky, I think,
just really met incredible people.
Learning I think, how to navigate it
and make the most of all the opportunities
because we're so fortunate in that.
There's just so many
incredible opportunities at Stanford.
And sometimes, it's almost so much
you feel bad
that you can't make everything.
You can't make every amazing speaker.
And I think, with time, you really learn
how to navigate that
and make the most of it
and you get really excited
and it's so cool.
Lee, give me one thing
that truly surprised you when you came.
You come in to Stanford, you're like,
"Wow. When I was back in Israel,
I did not realize
that this is going to be like this."
Oh, that's a tough one.
I think, honestly, for me,
a lot of it was just all these interests
that I really picked up.
And things that you have,
I guess, actually,
you probably knew me back then
but I don't know if you know this,
but I think, 12 year old Lee,
if you told her
she would be excited by FinTech,
or would have gone to computer science
or some business and technology
and get this excited, I don't know
if she would have believed you.
But I think it's discovering
all these different passions
and even the areas that you don't go into,
I have so much respect for all of my peers
that I see doing incredible things
in other spaces.
I have to say that for myself,
one of the things that really surprised me
was the amount of passion that I saw.
So, I knew it was a great institution,
I knew that it was a beautiful campus
and that the professors were great,
but sitting alongside peers that,
I looked at them as 18 year old,
people that I commanded,
soldiers that were older than them
just a month before I got to Stanford,
literally a month.
And for me, walking there
and thinking of them as children
and all of a sudden seeing their passion
and seeing them as equals
and we're having so much fun
and they're much smarter than me
and much better than me,
I think, to me, that was the greatest.
Talk to me, you choose to go
into computer science
and you go through that track.
You go through the systematic track
of the famous classes that we have
in our 106 series, and then you become
a sort of a teacher,
assistant section leader for that.
Yeah, definitely.
And I'll agree with you completely
on the passion component.
I think it's inspiring.
And it's people of every age, right?
It's 18 year olds, it's professors,
it's business students.
And for me, I didn't go in
unknowing I would do computer science.
I think a part of me almost tried
to not do that
because so many people were doing it.
But I took one course and I took another
and somehow it went okay, yeah,
or even well.
And I really enjoyed it.
And I liked how it teaches you
to break down problems
and think of the world.
And I think anyone who's ever coded
knows that there's no better feeling
of getting it to work right
after struggling with something.
And I got really lucky.
And I had incredible section leaders
and incredible teaching assistants
and professors during my courses.
And I've been very intimidated.
Stanford computer science,
I had no experience.
It was something I was scared of.
And then I finally got around
to doing it and I loved it.
And I thought,
Okay, I would like to be
one of the people who helped me
first get into this.
And I would like to help
teach this course.
I love it.
And it was great.
And you actually mentioned that
teaching students in the US [--],
but that's not necessarily true.
It's actually one of the most
commonly taken courses at Stanford
and we definitely see law students
taking it, too.
And it's just such a good place.
And it's great to see
what a variety of students
can enjoy this course,
whether it's computer science
as their main field of study or not.
So, Lee, paint me a picture.
Because it is one
of the most popular courses at Stanford.
It's notorious for being excellent
and excellent course that's been developed
over more than a decade.
The year actually
that you were section leading it,
so teaching other students,
you actually would change
an entire language from Java to Python,
which is I'm sure
was an interesting transition,
but paint me a picture.
A new student arrives at Stanford,
they go into the first
computer science class,
this is an incredible experience,
and I'd love for you
to maybe paint me a picture
of what that's like and what is the role
of the section leader
within that experience?
Yes, definitely.
And I think this is something very unique
that happens at Stanford.
And, of course,
it's dependent on resources.
But just a great model for teaching
is that in addition to these
very large lectures
with incredible professors,
they also really hire and teach and train
and make this community of students
who will help
with the teaching themselves.
And then you meet with students
in smaller groups,
maybe about 10 students once a week,
to reiterate what they learned in lecture
to actually do problem solving.
And for context, the lectures themselves
can be sometimes 300, 400 students, right?
Which is what people are looking
from the time and saying,
"This is not personalized."
"It's 400 students."
But the section is where you really get
the added value, right?
Yes. And for me, I remember
those were so helpful.
Just getting that practice
as opposed to lecture style learning,
which personally and I think
for many people, is a lot harder.
And then, also, when we grade their work,
we actually sit with students one on one.
We leave them notes virtually,
but we also meet with them in person
and really go over what went great;
what could have gone a little better;
how can they improve;
maybe give them ideas
for how they can take this
one step further,
go beyond the scope of the assignment.
And then there's also
a ton of office hours.
And I think it's that level
of feedback and interaction
that really sets us apart
and is the reason why these courses
get such great feedback
from every type of student.
And it's also great to see
how they've really built
this community of instructors
and they really value
and want our feedback
and how the course is going
both in the syllabus content style
of instruction in order to improve it.
Since they understand
that we have so much contact
with the students.
It reminds me a lot of the IDF mentorship
where age is not the factor.
Sometimes it's just another peer
that's teaching new material,
even though you may be more professional
in other fields like you have law.
Like second year law students
who are coming in
and you're teaching them computer science
and you're grading their work.
What do you tell a student
that is just starting out?
Because you're section leading
for one of the introductory
computer science courses,
which is the beginning of the funnel.
And one of the greatest challenges
that I know the faculty
and all around the world are dealing with,
both the diversity issue
that of the funnel, it's primarily males,
unfortunately, that continue.
And the reasons are flawed for that.
Because it actually turned out,
I believe I read a few research reports
that actually females perform better
in those courses than males do.
So, it's more of a social issue.
But what do you tell somebody
who's starting out
and they're having some trouble,
they're scared, it's difficult,
they don't recognize the language,
and they meet with Lee Alpert,
who's their section leader,
and they look at you as the teacher
because you're the one grading their work.
I think there are a lot of things.
One, and we do talk about this
and how to approach this problem.
I think, one the biggest thing I do is
I try to tell them,
"This was so hard for me too."
No one gets this right away
And also reflect on how far they've come
since they started.
And I think it's trying to find a way
to teach it which works for that student,
because not everyone is the same learner.
And there's so many different ways
to approach a problem,
especially in computer science.
And I think it's not giving up
and looking for that approach
that's right for the student.
And I think, it's actually really exciting
that you brought up this diversity,
because I'm not sure if you are part
of code in place that was,
No. Not this past quarter. No.
Tell me about it.
Yeah. It was this
really exciting initiative
that came together very fast
by some of the biggest
computer science professors at Stanford
and people who are involved
in the section leading program.
And they wanted to make this course,
or at least the first five weeks of it
accessible globally.
We have so many people studying remote.
For free?
For free. For free, remotely,
but have this style of teaching
incorporated into this program.
The same idea of section leading?
Same small cohorts?
Yes. So, in order to achieve that,
because, oh, I wish
I have the numbers for you,
but I know that we had
thousands of students
and we also had thousands
of volunteer teachers,
which was really really cool.
And I got to actually help train
some of those volunteer teachers
in the way that we do the section leading.
And it was great.
I had my Norwegian cousin
took the course.
People from all over the world
took this course
and it was really cool to see.
And the completion rates
for free courses that are in the style
tend to be really low because sometimes,
there isn't that intent.
If you're not getting a grade,
you haven't paid for it,
so, you don't feel the need.
But I think we did really well.
And it was such a cool
global process to see.
Especially with this issue of diversity
being so important.
Wow. Okay. Lee, all of that
is just fascinating.
But I want to make sure that I leave
two or three minutes to talk about
what you did in Greece.
I remember following your journey
on social media back then
and it was inspiring.
And you were volunteering there
for quite some time.
What were you doing with IsraAID
over in Lesvos, Greece?
Yes. So, I was a humanitarian fellow
with them.
IsraAID is a nonprofit that works really,
they go for humanitarian disasters
all over the world.
I was focused on their project
in Lesvos, Greece.
Unfortunately, Lesvos, Greece,
because of its location near Turkey,
became really when the refugee crisis
was at its peak, approximately 2015,
a lot of refugees from all over the world
were trying to access the EU
through the small island in Greece
on the border of Turkey.
And it was just a crisis.
It's home to Moria refugee camp,
named in a lot of articles
as one of the worst refugee camps
in the world.
And I was there helping with medical
and educational programs.
And it's really one of the most
important things I've done.
I got so much exposure.
I'm still in touch
with so many of the people I work with.
They're both people who are volunteers
and people who are themselves
asylum seekers.
How long did you spend on the island?
A month and a half, I think.
Wow.
And then I continue to stay in touch
with people and I try to speak at events
about what I've done.
And what was really neat there,
and the big lesson I learned there
was also just how I got involved with them
in the first place.
It definitely remains
one of the most important
life experiences I've had.
And I got involved with it
because a friend,
they were speaking at Stanford,
a friend knew of my interests in the area
and just suggested I come.
And I think a big lesson I got out of that
and continue to try and implement now
and hopefully always is just
make your passions known,
help each other out,
and then those around you
will let you know of opportunities,
there will be so much for you,
and to help each other out in that case
and connect friends
and make all of those things happen.
I think it's also inspiring
that as you come to Stanford,
you hear very quickly is,
what is your next internship;
and what a huge company
are you going to work at;
and what big name
are you going to put on your CV.
And the fact
that you're putting that aside
and you're saying,
"I want to first pursue a passion
and I want to pursue something
that I can actually make a dent
and an impact on people's lives."
And only through following you
a little bit through that summer,
I know that you've impacted so many lives.
So, I think
that's a really important message
that definitely people that I talk to
in freshman year at Stanford,
I try to share as well.
But Lee, I can't believe 20 minutes go by
way too fast. It's unbelievable.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yes, definitely.
I think, this is always a hard question.
It's the hardest.
We were just reflecting that Stanford asks
a similar question
on their  application process
and how difficult it was to answer.
It was hard then. It's hard now.
I think, I would like to hope
that thoughtful, that I take time
to consider a lot of perspectives
on each issue, i'm delving into.
Passionate. That if you do something,
give it 100%.
And excited just about all the things
there are to do and see.
I love it.
Lee, thank you very much. Toda raba.
Unfortunately, I don't think
I'll see you at campus
in the very very near future,
but hopefully later on.
And continue doing good for the world
and inspiring others.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Michael.
Have a good one.
Wonderful.